[Applause]
it's country night in calgary and yes
the stars have arrived for the ccma
awards now we're just having a blast i
love that
hey hi mom we're on the red carpet can
you get a two piece into a no piece girl
you're a masterpiece i'm not the middle
is that all right
we're just going to run it we're going
to have fun though i'm a professional
funder
[Music]
certified fun duo with our co-host
daniel towns and blanco brown
nicki minaj
you're in a music video with nicki minaj
i'm grateful i did it i was like
it's a crazy thing to be able to say you
did
yeah and the big winner of the night to
neil
to neil towns and the ccma award for
entertainer of the year goes to
nilton
becoming the most awarded artist of the
year denil racks up five wins total
including entertainer of the year and
female artist of the year for the fourth
time she wins again and again and again
and again what does it feel like
i'm in awe and i can't believe that it's
back here in calgary at home in alberta
[Music]
all right you two are here as a couple
tonight this is like a night out we got
our 10-year anniversary coming up in the
next month so we're just going to treat
this as a break from the kids and a
vacation and dallas wins big on date
night nabbing male artist of the year
and
fans choice i'm the male artist of the
year density i know i never in the
millionaires would have thought that my
musical taste and what what is around me
and my my my mom's influenced me on me
with country music would come around to
this point where i'm winning fans choice
at another the ccmas is pretty cool and
the ccma award for rising star
goes to
andrew hyatt
and first order of business calling his
wife we have some news for you
yeah i have one
yeah
presented by travel texas from the
pristine gulf coast to incredible arts
culture and outdoor adventure texas has
something for everyone texas go big or
go home